et revient sur ces deux grands meetings
du jour avec philippe pascot fric rives
un ex-conseiller municipal de manuel
valls à evry et gilles à casanova
spécialiste en communication
bonsoir messieurs crient merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france jules
casanova aujourd'hui cet eric zemmour
qui suscite l'ire de ces manifestants
dit antifa
vous savez pier paolo pasolini a
expliqué que la prochaine vague fasciste
portera le nom anti fasciste parce que
au fond cette idée d'interdire la parole
d'interdire un propos c'est une idée qui
n'est pas la démocratie lorsque la
gauche a quelque chose à dire elle dit
quelque chose est en général l'extrême
droite n'a pas beaucoup de poids ou de
prises entre 1947 et
1983 l'extrême droite a représenté entre
deux et trois et demi pour cent des voix
lorsque la gauche partir du tournant de
84 a du mal à tenir un discours de
gauche qui répondent aux attentes des
populations qu'elle est censée
représenter alors vous avez un retour de
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui 60 70 % des
ouvriers et des employés ont voté ou
votent tous s'apprêtent à voter pour des
partis qui sont considérés comme l
extrême droite ce n'est pas en faisant
des manifestations de rue que la gauche
peut avancer ce quelque chose en positif
c'est en ayant un programme en ayant une
proposition on renouant avec sa capacité
à représenter les catégories populaires
philippe pascot eric zemmour taxe est
aujourd'hui par ses militants
anti-fascistes taxé de 10 kg et l'az la
haine il ya quelques temps pas si loin
que ça c'était marine le pen qui se
retrouvaient objet de sécréter comment
est-ce que vous quel regard est ce que
vous portez sur ce qui ressemble à une
évolution
une évolution survie j'appelle ça plutôt
une régression maintenant moi je suis
pas inquiet je compare zemmour et marine
le pen je connais bien
à deux fusées macro nien il arrange
macron la différence qu'il ya entre les
deux c'est que la fusée zemmour comme
les autres a explosé en plein vol et la
fusée marine le pen comme d'habitude
elle n'arrivera jamais à décoller je
suis d'accord est ce que disait mon
prédécesseur la gauche aujourd'hui qui
malheureusement n'arrive pas à trouver
un discours cohérent ben se rabat en
miaulant après les extrêmes et leur
donne plus de voix autre chose mais moi
je suis pas la caisse des mourres il va
exploser gentiment que la vol parce que
de toute manière ce qu'il raconte lui
marine le pen c'est tellement creux que
ça peut pas aller loin c'est une bulle
donc la bulle il en train de gonfler il
ya des gens qui souffle dedans
les gens désabusés les gens qui ont eu
marre de la gauche les gens qu'on ai eu
marre de la droite les gens qui savent
plus vers qui se tourner aujourd'hui il
ya un homme neuf qu'ils ont l'impression
qu'il est neuf il s'appelle zemmour donc
on va le voir mais vous savez les gens
sont très volatiles très très volatile
aujourd'hui son toit l'extrême droite
parce que il ya les médias qui sont
derrière il ya les médias qui pousse
quand vous voyez la façon dont zemmour
est poussé dans tous les médias
officiels
c'est normal que les gens qui ne
regardent que bfm ou hanouna suivent
monsieur et mots mais je vous dis ça va
être une grosse fusée qui va exploser en
plein vol et zemmour il va se réduire
comme un paquet de cacahuètes flétri et
marine le pen comme d'habitude ne
décollera pas mais les seules personnes
que ça arrange ces deux phénomènes de
foire je dis bien ces deux faits
viennent deux fois c'est le monsieur
macron qui en ce moment est en train de
se lécher les babines parce qu'on parle
pas de lui on parle pas de son programme
on parle pas de sa non candidature vous
rendez compte qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
type qui n'est pas candidat qui se sert
de la présidence et qui a déjà ses
signatures il ya quand même un malaise
et ça personne n'en parle parce qu'on
est tellement occupée par le phénomène
zemmour est et lepéniste qu'on fait pas
attention au reste moi j'y fais même pas
grave zemmour ces deux-là de la roupie
de sansonnet pour moi on a du mal à
croire à une coïncidence à enjil
casanova c'est deux candidats de la
droite nationaliste qui tiennent meeting
le même jour qui veut faire passer un
message à l'autre quel message
la question c'est
la question c'est celui d'un vote
qui s'adresse à la même
disons partie de l'électorat une partie
qui est déçue par la gauche et une
partie qui est déçu par la droite et là
on voit bien que on est d'un certain
point de vue un petit peu dans une
situation comparable aux rapports entre
georges marchais et françois mitterrand
il ya 50 ans françois mitterrand n'avait
rien il avait une petite formation qui
s'appelait la convention des
institutions républicaines et le parti
communiste et 25% des voix et puis
françois mitterrand a surgi et l'a fait
de la politique il a conquis un parti
politique qu'il a renouvelés revitaliser
et il est passé devant les communistes
qui avaient pourtant les gros bataillons
l'idée d'eric zemmour c'est un petit peu
la même c'est à dire arriver à prendre à
marine le pen les gros bataillons de ce
vote le seul problème c'est que cela
s'est passé sur dix ans entre françois
mitterrand et le parti communiste
français alors que là il voudrait que ça
se passe en 10 semaines c'est beaucoup
plus difficile
ce que l'on peut penser c'est que au
dernier moment les électeurs de ce parti
de l'électorat choisiront de faire un
vote utile c'est à dire que celui que
les sondages donneront en position
d'être véritablement au deuxième tour ou
en tout cas d'être vraiment en tête
attrapera les sondages de l'autre et on
ne peut pas penser qu'il y aura par les
sondages les votes par dont on ne peut
pas penser qu'il y aura deux
candidats qui seront au coude à coude
alors que leur programme n'est pas
véritablement distants si l'on voit
l'ensemble du champ politique qui est
présenté à cette présidentielle philippe
passe quand on entendait à l'instant
j'ai le casanova
revenir sur la gauche de françois
mitterrand allait ou aujourd'hui tout
simplement la gauche en france
elle est dans ses baskets elle se
cherche il ya plus de gauche aujourd'hui
il ya plus de droite n'ont plus
aujourd'hui sophie quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui un type comme robert hue qui
soutient macron dire que le buffet qui
soutient qu'à buffet la présidente de
région qui soutient taubira les mecs qui
vont à droite les mecs qui vont en
bouche il ya plus de gauche joly il ya
plus de droits non plus il ya des gens
qui se cherchent aujourd'hui il ya un
peuple qui cherche un leader il ya un
peuple et qui cherchent un renouveau il
ya un peuple qui est en train de se dire
on en a marre du mec qui nous a dirigé
pendant cinq ans via un type peut-être
car il peut être que ça va être le
meilleur
y'a pas de gauche aujourd'hui et
honnêtement il n'y a pas de droite
aujourd'hui quand vous tapez promener
madame pécresse c'est la même chose que
macron quand vous prenez les différentes
gauches qui sont en train de se
présenter un chat n'y retrouverait pas
ses petits
aujourd'hui est le problème il est là
c'est que les gens ne savent pas donc il
se dirige vers celui qui a l'air le plus
neuf le plus le plus honnête entre
guillemets entre guillemets parce que
pour trouver de l'honnêteté j'ai tous
les candidats il faut vraiment chercher
très loin moi j'ai dit que le chose la
plus importante en juin à retenir pour
les électeurs c'est qu'il faut changer
la façon dont tour mag aujourd'hui on
votait on choisissait au premier tour et
on éliminer au deuxième
aujourd'hui je pense que les gens il
faut qu'ils aient éliminé au premier
tour et on verra ce qui reste au
deuxième mais surtout éliminons au
premier tour pour revenir sur le duel à
eric zemmour marine le pen j'ai le
casanova comment est-ce que vous
analysez la communication aujourd'hui de
la chef de file du rassemblement
national face à eric zemmour on l'a
entendu suggéré ce samedi à son rival je
la cite de faire le ménage dans son
mouvement après l'avoir accusé de
communautarisme et d'attirer dans sa
campagne des catholiques
traditionalistes des pailles ans et
quelques nazis
pourquoi pourquoi cette arme qu'est ce
qu'elle cherche
alors nous on est là dans un phénomène
qui semble plutôt de l'ordre du
caractére aux logiques voilà une dame de
la famille le pen qui a essayé de
dédiaboliser et son image de
dédiaboliser l'image de sa famille et
qui a dû être obligé de rompre largement
avec son père et plus largement encore
avec beaucoup d'amis de son père qu'elle
a dû écarter de la direction et même du
parti et puis voilà que ces gens comme
ils ont été écartés par la famille le
pen vont se retrouver derrière eric
zemmour et ça va ça l'énervent parce que
c'est elle qui à l'image sulfureuse
beaucoup plus qu'eric zemmour qui est
connu comme un éditorialiste de
télévision de radio de presse écrite
depuis de nombreuses années et qui est
beaucoup plus admis par l'establishment
que le nom le pen alors on comprend très
bien humainement
kèkè lequel qu'elle en est gros sur la
patate dire et on en langage populaire
mais d'un autre côté son discours de
dire attention il ya des vrais nazis là
bas il faut faire barrage ça ressemble
aux discours des castors régulièrement
utilisé pour la faire perdre au second
tour donc elle joue contre elle même
philippe pascot l'arrivée d'eric zemmour
a évidemment bousculer le champ
politique il marchant sur les plates
bandes de marine le pen qui est elle
installé depuis de nombreuses années le
discours de marine le pen a évolué on en
parlait à l'instant avec un gilles
casanova elle revendique aujourd'hui une
certaine normalisation normalisation qui
a été décrié au sein du rm face à ce
discours a beaucoup plus virulent d'eric
zemmour est ce qu elle le défend
clairement aujourd'hui escale latium par
stratégie 7 dédiabolisation face au
leader de reconquête pour de quoi ils se
balancent des petits cailloux les
figures on est dans une cour de
récréation des nazis y en a dans deux
côtés y en a chez zemmour il y en a chez
ayant lâché marine le pen ça veut rien
dire encore une fois il centra d'amuser
la galerie et pendant qu'ils amusent la
galerie et ben les gens ne regardent pas
ce qui se passe ailleurs l'ensemble de
la médiatisation aujourd'hui de
l'élection présidentielle se passe autre
les petites phrase de zemmour et les
petites phrases de marine le pen mais
ces gains grands n'importe quoi mais bon
ça marche donc qui continue et les
désabusés les gens qui savent vraiment
pas vers qui se tourner et ben écoute
ses discours lénifiants et qu'il prend
qui prône des gros principe vous rendez
compte on parle de nazis pour la
présidentielle mais on parle pas des
maisons de retraite on parle pas du club
du travail on parle pas de futur on
parle pas de l'environnement parle de
rien c'est ça une présidentielle pas
pour moi mais je vous dis encore une
fois zemmour macron 10 arrange le
président en place il arrange les mac
rognan pendant ce temps là monsieur
macro sur son petit fauteuil de nos
candidats se lèchent les babines il faut
que les gens se rendent compte que le le
vrai enjeu il n'est pas entré moore et
marine le pen de toute manière même s'il
y en a un des deux qui arrive au
deuxième tour ils franchiront pas la
barre du deuxième tour donc le gros du
problème sur cette élection c'est de
savoir si on va encore pendant cinq ans
un type qui nous a menti pendant cinq
ans et je cite monsieur bacrot en
personne on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cet échange qui lis pas ce
qu'on écrit van ex conseiller municipal
de manuel valls à evry et gilles la
casanova spécialiste en communication